it is strange times with everybody stuck
indoors as we mentioned how can people
show their pride right now I think I
know it's it's a rough time and people
are you know trying to figure out how to
abide their time and everything like
that but I think just being a social
media and connecting with people through
that way and showing your pride and any
kind of social media platform is one way
to do it if you're stuck indoors and
that's how we're all communicating now
and that's really all we can do I think
you know just trying to look at the
positive things on social media and um
just try to try and light enlighten
ourselves through that mm-hmm
what does it mean to you guys to be the
first male same-sex couple on 90 day
fiancé is how important is this
visibility on a popular franchise like
this oh well to us it's really important
because um we want to show true love you
want to show that two men can be in love
that they can have a family that they
can you know for lack of a better word
be normal and be be happy there's it's
not always Romeo and Juliet it can be
Romeo and Romeo yes did you ever imagine
in your wildest dreams that you would be
on 90 day fiancé how did this
opportunity present itself
well I our mother didn't know anything
about night a fiance and I had been
watching a couple seasons of it but I
never thought we could be on it or it
never entered my mind because it's where
the Florida comes to America to marry
the American and then last summer when
the other way debuted on TLC I said
that's exactly what I'm doing because I
knew I was gonna be moving here so I
talked your ma nobody went on YouTube
and stuff to look at the show and I said
you want to just you know um see what
happens and so we did so we just applied
and it was a long process but and then
we talked a lot about it through that
process if we still want to do it
we want to go through with it stuff like
that because we're kind of private
people in a way but you know like said
we wanted to show people that you know
love is love and same-sex relationships
are just like everybody else's mm-hmm
they imagine there are a lot of
obstacles overcome hurdles to jump over
when you are can you know leaving your
home to go live somewhere else to go
live in Mexico and Armando for you to
invite him into your home
how has actually you know showing that
on television affected the process of
this entire thing for you both I think
it has an effect just negatively at all
we got along really well long distance
for a long time we busy each other quite
a few times and like said I know it's a
different platform that a lot of people
do when they get together with somebody
but I think it's actually helped just in
a lot of ways that you know we're a team
with this through the good and the bad
that we have each other's back and we're
just a team through the whole thing it
all has been a learning process
you know meshing the cultures together
we have an age difference but all in all
I think you know being there for each
other and understanding each other
through it all has brought us even
closer together mm-hmm
we've already seen a lot of emotional
moments in the episodes that have aired
so far what can we expect in the rest of
the season coming up there's a lot going
to be happening there's a lot more
emotions where you can tell were very
emotional default so that you'll see a
lot of that there's a lot more tears
there's a lot of happiness there's a lot
of struggles as well we have to go
through a lot of different things that I
can't really say exactly what happens
you have to tune in for it but there are
things that happen that surprised us and
a lot of roadblocks to get to this point
that we're at right now
and I allow these things that we went
through
they were completely new to me so a lot
of it is I think that's why the emotions
were there because I was new I was born
to these different things about being in
a relationship with a man and also Kenny
being older than me he had already gone
past a lot of these hurdles and kind of
now having to relive those with me I
think it kind of was a surprise to
himself as well so going through that
together is something you'll all be able
to see on the show yeah you know we
talked at the beginning of this about
the visibility that you guys have
showing your relationship on this show
on this franchise have you been able to
keep track of audience reaction have
people reached out to you saying how
they've been affected by what they've
seen so far yes Xtra Armando he posted a
story that a woman who's very religious
she did not really accept um gay people
in her life and it changed her mind
and she said it really opened up her her
heart and that's just one person and one
person is enough but we can change one
person's mind then it's a win-win but
we've actually got a lot of those
already that are really saying you know
you guys are great and you really opened
my mind and they were having trouble
struggling like when their son came out
or their daughter came out and they're
seeing that they can have a great life
and they could fall in love with
somebody of the same sex and have an
amazing relationship and it's not all
good and bad you know same-sex
relationships are just like everybody
else some make it some don't some have
troubles some don't it's a learning
process - mm-hmm Armando have been gone
from never hearing about this show
before so now being so heavily involved
in it what's your take on the whole
experience of exposing your story and
exposing your life and all of these ups
and downs that you're going through to
all these people watching well it was I
something that Kenya and I talked back
and forth on before joining the show
again I didn't know anything about it so
I kind of started doing my research but
we both are very private person people
or we were so we were like you know what
are we sure we want to do this you know
we shouldn't because of this but then a
sign of us was like you know what this
could help some people um so in the end
I thought you know speaking for myself
I'm like I've gone through some tough
times in my life and I just want to be
there able to show people that um no
matter what you know we can be who we
are and I just I kind of want to
enlighten people I want them to make
choices to where they they can live in
their own skin be themselves be happy
and be proud of that and so I hope I do
through showing our story we show that
and we can help people out there that
either are struggling with their
sexuality or people that don't agree
with same-sex couples mm-hmm and can in
your move to Mexico what has been the
most surprising thing about about your
experience so far something you might
not have expected well um as you saw on
the show like I was very emotional and
upset I'm just saying
gonna be leaving my children and my
grandson that was the hardest thing to
do in my life it was very difficult and
you'll see in the next upcoming a couple
episodes of me actually leaving it is
very very hard I was surprised myself
how difficult it was to leave to
separate myself and come in here you
know you get a sense of loneliness and
then it was a little bit odd for me here
because I can't talk to anybody except
don't speak Spanish here so it was very
hard to even like be with other people
because I couldn't speak to them and I'm
an independent person and it's hard
relying on Armando a lot because he has
to translate for me every place we go so
the biggest obstacle that has been the
language barrier and because I'm an
outgoing person it's hard to like kind
of go back a little bit um in that way
so that's
the most difficult parts of it oh hey
there if you want more LGBTQ news and
exclusive interviews click Subscribe or
watch these videos